E
WRONG DIRECTION.
THAT'S "THE ANGLE."
20 WHEN I WAS KEVIN HASSETT,
FORMER CHAIR OF THE COUNCIL OF
ECONOMIC ADVISORS UNDER TRUMP
AND HOOVER INSTITUTE FELLOW.
IN OCTOBER 2021 YOU WENT OUT ON
A LIMB AND YOU PREDICTED A
RECESSION.
WHAT DID YOU SEE THEN THAT
BIDEN'S TEAM OBVIOUSLY MISSED OR
JUST NEW BUT DECIDED TO IGNORE?
>> SURE.
THANK GOODNESS YOU'VE BEEN WAY
OUT IN FRONT OF THE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THE CORRECT
ECONOMICS.
WHAT WE SAW WAS THAT INFLATION
WAS SPINNING OUT OF CONTROL,
ACCELERATING.
THAT WAS GOING TO EITHER RUN WAY
AHEAD OF ANY WAGE INCREASES.
PEOPLE WERE GOING TO BE WORSE
OFF.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS RIGHT
NOW JUST SUSPECTED WERE GOING TO
HAPPEN BUT NOW WE KNOW.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN FAMILY HAS
TO SPENT $460 MORE THIS MONTH IN
ORDER TO BUY THE SAME STUFF THEY
BOUGHT LAST YEAR AT THIS TIME.
IF YOUR WAGE DIDN'T GO UP BY
MORE THAN $5,000 THIS YEAR, THEN
YOU ARE WORSE OFF.
SO GDP HAS GOT TO DECLINE.
PEOPLE CAN'T BUY THE SAME AMOUNT
OF STUFF THEY BOUGHT LAST YEAR
AND THAT'S WHAT WE ARE SEEING.
WE HAVE TWO NEGATIVE CORNERS.
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN A RECESSION
IN THE PAST.
THIRD-QUARTER NUMBER LIKE IT'S
GOING TO BE NEGATIVE.
AMERICANS ARE HURTING IN THE
METRIC OF HOW THEY'RE HURTING,
THE $460 A MONTH, THAT'S A HUGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO HAVE TO SPEND
TO JUST TREAD WATER.
>> Laura: IT'S GETTING WORSE
THAN THAT.
ANY WAGE GAINS THAT AMERICANS
HAVE SEEN HAVE BEEN TOTALLY
SWAMPED BY THE 8.3% RISE IN THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX.
SO YOU MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN A WAGE
INCREASE BUT FOR THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN THAT IS STILL LOST
MONEY.
YOUR ACCOUNTS ARE GOING DOWN.
YOUR SAVINGS IS GOING DOWN IF
YOU HAVE ANY TO BEGIN WITH SO
THAT'S WHY.
YOUR CASH IS WORTH LESS BECAUSE
OF INFLATION AND THE COSTS ARE
GOING UP.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IF WE GO TO THE FINANCIAL
SECTOR, IN THE STOCK MARKET, IF
YOU PUT $10,000 IN THE STOCK
MARKET WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK
OFFICE, IT ABOUT DOUBLED OVER
HIS FOUR YEARS.
IT'S DOWN ABOUT 30% THIS YEAR.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, WHAT THAT
MEANS IS FOR THE TYPICAL
AMERICAN FAMILY THAT HAS LITTLE
MORE THAN $100,000 IN WEALTH,
THAT MEANS THEY LOST ABOUT
$30,000.
SO NOT ONLY DO YOU HAVE TO SPEND
THAT EXTRA $460 A MONTH BUT YOUR
WEALTH IS DOWN BY THAT MUCH AS
WELL.
FINALLY WITH THE FED HIKING
RATES, HOME PRICES ARE GOING TO
TAKE A BIG HIT.
THEY WILL PROBABLY DROP 20 OR
30%.
ALL THE ASSETS THAT TYPICAL
AMERICANS OWN ARE HEADED SOUTH
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S BECAUSE OF THESE TERRIBLE
POLICIES.
>> Laura: IN TODAY'S SPEECH TO
THE NEA, THE PRESIDENT CONTINUED
HIS INFLATION BLAME GAME.
WATCH.
>> INHERITING OF FAILED MAGA
REPUBLICAN ECONOMY.
WE CONFRONTED THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AND PUTIN'S WAR IN
UKRAINE.
THAT HAS DRIVEN THE GLOBAL
INFLATION WE HAVE SEEN TODAY.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE PASS THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT.
>> Laura: THIS IS SO BAD.
I DON'T KNOW WHO'S WRITING THIS.
WHERE DOES THE BUCK STOP
EXACTLY?
>> THE BUCK STOPS REALLY WITH
THE FOLKS, THE CAREER ECONOMISTS
THAT LET HIM SAY STUFF LIKE
THAT.
THE FACT IS IT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT IF THE
GOVERNMENT PRINTS MONEY AND
MAILS IT TO PEOPLE LIKE A
HELICOPTER DROP WHICH IS WHAT
BIDEN HAS DONE.
AT THE SAME TIME ATTACKING
SUPPLY.
THEN YOU GET INFLATION.
THIS IS WHAT LARRY SUMMERS SAW,
JASON FUHRMAN SAW, THIS IS WHAT
I'VE SEEN.
I WAS AT THE JACKSON HOLE
CONFERENCE WERE -- WHERE
JAY POWELL KIND OF SCARED
MARKETS.
IT WAS CLEAR THEN.
THERE WAS A SOUND ACADEMIC PAPER
PRESENTED THAT IT WAS BIDEN'S
POLICY THAT CAUSED INFLATION TO
LIFT OFF.
AGAIN, CAN YOU IMAGINE.
THEY HAD 6% GROWTH THAT THEY
INHERITED BECAUSE WE HAVE
BASICALLY COVID SHUTDOWNS.
I REGRET BEING PART OF THE TEAM
THAT DID THAT BUT WE HAD
ECONOMIC POLICIES THAT GOT US
BACK UP AND GOING AND THAT'S WHY
WE HAD TWO QUARTERS OF 6% GROWTH
WHICH IS A REALLY HIGH GROWTH
NUMBER.
NOW WE ARE LOOKING AT PROBABLY
THE THIRD NEGATIVE QUARTER IN A
ROW IN THE FED TIGHTENING.
THERE'S REALLY NO SAYING HOW BAD
THIS IS GOING TO BE.
ESPECIALLY IF THERE'S NOT A
CHANGE IN POLICYMAKING IN
WASHINGTON.
>> Laura: EVERYONE'S GOT TO